ramsay show you can be intentional about
your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr
john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
so we will be talking about your life
and all of your problems because he's
good at that
and we'll also talk about your money
because i'm here
and we're glad you're with us thanks for
hanging out you're good at that
well you are good at helping people with
their problems i'm going to give you
that
i'm going to give you that one you're
good at talking about money i am i've
it's worked out for me it's working i'm
hoping it's going to be a career
working out for you you hang in there
dave and you keep working hard
like a hair and a biscuit all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money jana is with us in
orlando hey jana what's up
hi thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
um i have a real estate money question
we
with my husband's job going mostly
remote we have the opportunity to move
back to kansas city which is our
hometown
from florida where we've been for about
three years and
so moving back towards family and we
have a paid for house here
and we've been without a mortgage for
about three and a half years so moving
back
we feel like we have options but we're
having a hard time narrowing it down
whether it's going to be lake or by a
few acres or
even build is on the list we can't
we can't quite decide um so we're trying
to
decide now if we should just buy what's
on the market when it's time
or give it some time and rent in the
meantime
so we can have um i don't know just
experience the process moving to florida
we i didn't even see my house before we
moved into it
it was a little bit more of a quick
thing and it worked out and it was great
but
i kind of want to enjoy the process this
time but we're
we're going back and forth whether
that's worth it or not do we
take our time and rent and spend that
money that we haven't had to spend each
month or
go ahead and
[Laughter]
yeah but anyway uh uh well here's the
thing
uh how long you been going we've been
gone three years
okay so you know the market still you
know which neighborhood is which you
kind of know i don't want to be over
there i do want to be over there
that kind of we know the county that we
want to be in we know we have it
narrowed down to certain areas certain
lakes
certain country areas
if you don't find the thing that you
want in those areas then it would be
rent
and patience until you find the thing
you want but if you find the thing you
want there's no rule that says you have
to not
get it right right i hear in your voice
a very
i hear in your voice a very kind way
usage of the word we what what's you
know this place is where you're from
what's the hank what's the hold up um
my husband is real decisive and i'm real
not
yes and i think he'd be okay
yeah because i'm that way i can make a
decision if i don't like it i'll just
make another decision meanwhile sharon's
still thinking
yep yep that's kind of how we are
and i kind of want i i was okay with
that on the way here because
i was excited to come and all i wanted
was a pool in florida
well you're going to buy as you move
it needs to go at a slow enough pace
that you process it
you not him because we already know he
can process it
but that you process it in a way that it
involves enjoyment
pleasure this is a time of your life
you've earned the right to pay cash for
property because you're moving from a
paid for property
you know the area this should be a
pleasurable
by and large moving never is completely
but i mean it's like a root canal but a
pleasurable
a pleasurable process for you if you
feel rushed jammed
pushed hustled frustrated
chill just rent yeah but if you found
the right thing
and you had the appropriate number of
hours or days to
emotionally process it while you were
making an offer then there's no
limitation right and we we're still
holding out hope that there's going to
be that place that we both get excited
about whether it's
lake or land well guys this is it my
guess is you're gonna rent and it's
gonna take a while because you're on a
bit of a treasure hunt
a little bit yeah so then my question is
um what i mean in that kind of a
situation
most places like to have a year lease
and
how much would we then i mean we could
spend whatever we want i guess
on rent but we don't want to waste our
money so then how do you determine how
much rent
you are spending money to buy patients
right
so how much is how much is it worth to
you that's what the question you got to
ask
you maybe you want to negotiate with the
landlord up front that says hey if we
find another place
and we can find you a replacement tenant
you'll agree to release us
okay something like that as a landlord i
i happily will release any tenant early
from a lease if i have a replacement
okay because i often can increase the
rent when they leave so i love
replacements
okay yeah and i haven't looked into
specific rentals so maybe i need to
explore that a little bit more that's
not going to happen with a corporate
rental like the apartment complex that's
managed out of atlanta or some such crap
right
but mom and pop like me that's got a
house over here with a
rent sign from walmart in the front yard
they'll do all kinds of deals with them
as long as it makes sense for them
right so i guess we just need to decide
what size of a house because it's going
to go anywhere from a four bedroom for
eighteen hundred a month
to a two bedroom which would be cramped
with our two kids
it's closer to twelve hundred the money
stop the whining about the money you've
got the money
you're trying to create a process here
that you i mean you're millionaires okay
i can feel it i know the numbers i know
i know the vibe on this so
you're there so just enjoy you're gonna
blow
15 20 000 bucks for patience
to get the right property and that's
what you're going to spend on rent for a
year while you just sit
there and enjoy the process of finding
the right property getting the land
bought
you may even extend the release a little
bit while you build the house that's
right
so just just do it at a pace there's no
you know one of the things money gives
you is margin it gives you wiggle room
and you've got the money to have wiggle
room without forcing yourself anyway
you know and but when you're broke it's
always you know you're just pushed in
the corner
and uh god i hate that feeling because
right about the time i do that's when i
do something stupid
every time i do something stupid when
that happens that's right yeah i have
that pressure that i'm jammed up
i mean i can't tell you how many times
somebody said well the car broke down so
i bought a new car
you know it's like what then you just
fix your freaking car
you know but it broke down they just
break down all the time you know it's
that
it's that same thing that's going on is
that but they're
you know the the hassle of fixing a 500
thing on a car when you're broke is a
big freaking deal
well in our house we're not broke and
just a couple days ago my wife said hey
we got to fix a seat belt we could still
have a child seat back there we got to
fix a seat belt
and the first words out of my mouth were
is it just time for us to get a new car
no one's been there a while and she said
i mean while you're on the show that'd
be nice
and so i started thinking through and
talking i got to be on the show with
dave i can't
well i mean it's just it's just what you
said it's like
or yeah 300 bucks solves the seat belt
problem
and i mean it's just how quick it was
well
clearly we need to throw this thing in
the lake and start her question is a
really good question
it is but that doesn't sound like a
money issue to me no it's a process
it is a heart issue it's a process issue
it's he makes decisions real fast and
he's jammed her up before
hmm forced her in i know this because
i've done it to my wife for 38 years
and if this is going to be the forever
house which doesn't exist but this is
going to be
it there's no forever house i want to do
slow go slow and make my dream house
until your freaking dream changes okay
so shut up you don't there's no such
thing it's a house let's go buy it
this is the ramsey shop
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out
at chministries.org backslash
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
getting a cup of coffee before the show
and i ran into one of our new team
members who
asked him how he's doing he said well
better today but over the weekend his
new house that he was trying to buy here
got sideways because this market is so
white hot that he got leap frogged and
somebody pushed him out of a deal and so
you had to start again
you know if you've been paying attention
the real estate market this year you've
known the competition for a property is
high there's low inventory right now
and prices are going up in a lot of
markets really fast it's hard to find a
property
when inventory is low it means there's
more buyers buying than sellers selling
and that turns the pressure up buyers
want to snag the right house and
sometimes
uh when you're doing that if you're not
careful you get stupid
because you go how it's like a beagle
chasing a rabbit you know
i gotta go i gotta get hey and you like
keep upping the offer to the point that
you're in the stupid zone
to win in this market you really need a
pro walking with you going
nick calm down calm down
our agents in our elp program our
endorsed local provider program have
years of industry success in any market
and they can walk you through and help
you navigate
the weirdness of this post-covered
market
text the word house to connect with an
endorsed local provider
text the word house to three three seven
eight nine that's thirty three
seven eighty nine stephen's with us
stephen is in columbus ohio hi stephen
how are you hi dave how are you sir
better than i deserve that's for sure
how can i help
you had to hear that um got a question
for you have a young
entrepreneur daughter we actually just
recently put in a
new commercial kitchen basically in our
house
she started up a bakery doing ice sugar
cookies and it's just kind of
taken off kind of blowing up actually um
and it was curious what to do with
um kind of setting her up for the future
what what your recommendation is for a
10 year old
to do with her money besides so up in
the stages and count
so how much has she made with her sugar
cookies
um it's kind of you know it goes month
to month depending on holidays you know
it started yeah
i mean just roughly i mean um
i'm going to say roughly she's right at
a month
last month was like 5 50 this month
pushing the thousand bucks
oh that's awesome wow that's great man
okay
well here's what i'm gonna do when i get
done i'm gonna put you on hold kelly's
gonna pick up i'm gonna send you a copy
of anthony o'neil's
teen entrepreneur toolbox which is a
toolbox that
helps parents work with their teenagers
on setting up and running a
small business appropriately here's the
main thing i want parents to remember
about money and about entrepreneurship
when you're 10 12 14 even 16 years old
the investing in some big investment
that's going to be worth 8 bazillion
dollars when you're 65 years old
is some fun math to run out and it's not
a bad teaching tool
but then but 99 of what your 10 year old
needs to take away from this experience
is the entrepreneurial skills and
confidence
it's not the money the money and the
scope of her life is irrelevant because
you have a young rock star on your hands
and so you know like when rachel was
growing up rachel cruz
you know sharon i kept looking at each
other going we have to point this one at
something because it's going to go off
you know and that's what you're doing
here right you your god you know
your your children in the bible says are
an arrow in your
quiver and so what you want is you want
them to fly
straight when you release the bow
and that's what this is all about it's
not about a thousand dollars a month
because it's not fifteen thousand
dollars a month it's a thousand dollars
okay and in the scope of this kid's life
she's gonna make a hundred thousand
dollars a month if you keep teaching her
these skills
and so i think what you need to do is
make sure you lean in on the lessons
and then i always take money with adults
and children and i divide it into three
categories
we enjoy some called spending we
give some called generosity and we save
some
and you always all of us including 10
year olds need to be building
those three muscles at all times
the problem is often with children we
only teach them one or two of the
muscles
and it's not it's not optional either
it's freaking mandatory
like brushing your teeth or taking your
test and getting a grade
and going to bed when i tell you to
because i'm an
old school papa dave so uh you know that
kind of stuff so this is you're going to
save some
and here's why i'm going to show you why
you're going to give some and here's why
i'm going to show you why we're going to
talk about it and you're going to enjoy
some
because sometimes you have a kid that's
a little tightwad doesn't want to give
doesn't want to give or doesn't want to
enjoy
sometimes you have a little spender and
they want to spend it all but you
and so they got a natural bent but also
help them develop those other skills and
these entrepreneurial skills
and that's what i want to concentrate on
here
and so under the heading of savings if
you want to sit down and continue a
deeper education with the smartvestor
pro
you can open up a little mutual fund if
you want to and put some of the money in
there
that's okay but the the moral of the
story is is this
kid is the magic sauce not the money
right
and dave tell me what you think about
this
while he was talking i was thinking
about myself as a parent of a 10 year
old
and my 10 year old gets really
zoned in on something for sometimes
months at a time
and it takes a couple of months and then
suddenly i start reading about it i get
on board and then i think all right i'll
learn about dinosaurs and then
right when i start thinking about it
he's off to the next thing
it can be really easy for the parents
as you were talking about to lose the
importance of the lessons here
and suddenly it becomes about keeping
this business running
right and not forgetting hey she's 10.
yeah right yeah
absolutely two months it might be soccer
that she's this passionate about shut it
down
shut it down it's sugar cookies don't
make your 10 year old have an roi on a
professional kitchen you may not need to
see this is what happens that's why i
asked what real money was he said she's
making
a lot of money and that is a lot of
money for 10. but i've also
had the call here where you've got the
child star that's right
you know and they you know they made a
hundred thousand did a commercial and
made a hundred thousand bucks right
freaking diaper commercial the
three-year-old got a hundred grand you
know what that's happened i've talked to
those people
and if you're not careful then the
parents get all invested and you're
that's how their their childhood gets
stolen
because they become a product they
become a professional right and they
become about their achievement and how
much money you're going to make
consensus and that's why we all gripe
about parents who overdo sports or
gripe about parents who overdo pageants
right or gripe about parents that overdo
dot dot dot because they're trying to
live some kind of very vicarious crap
right through their kiddo and he's not
doing that there's no sign of that in
his call at all
none whatsoever but that's the warning
is encourage
nourish the positive things guide them
give them some boundaries some guard
rails
so that this can be a healthy thing not
a toxic thing
but you can hold it really loosely yeah
hold it loose yeah they don't need to be
up two o'clock in the morning making
cookies you know i mean it's
don't send your 10 year old salt mines
and he wasn't doing that yeah and
most people don't but sometimes people
go well the kid needs to go where the
kid's going to go
no no they're a kid they're 10. you need
to you need to go no you're going to bed
you're going to bed it's a sugar cookie
shut the crap up go to bed you know i
mean this
is it you know and so you got to draw
the line there and and
back it in because uh you know adults
because if you don't then you've got a
30 year old with an expanded version of
that
and that's then they end up in your on
your show
yes calling in going i'm crazy
so they've lost their ever-loving mind
and that's not how they call
your show but it's i mean it's this is
the actual diagnosis
sort of well but yeah i mean it's so
it's so easy
to take what your kid's passionate about
and it becomes your passion and suddenly
you're driving them towards an outcome
instead of letting be a kid yeah and
then you get you know you can name all
these stars that were stars too young
right the teenaged or that didn't have
parents who had good boundaries well
parents were just crazier than
loon and then the kid just made a blew
up made a bunch of money and
as a country star a pop star or whatever
14 years old and then all you've got is
expanded dysfunction right
later on because they never had the
ability to emotionally relationally
develop
and and have good solid boundaries and
process now again he's not got any of
that there was
no smell of that sounds like he's like
he loves his daughter yeah you sound
like he's proud he's very proud of her
and he should be she's a cool kid
that's a cool kid i mean that's neat but
the moral there is don't overthink it
yeah yeah and don't make it in a savings
account and local but i mean you don't
have to when you when you look down and
you go
five i mean a ten-year-old thousand
dollars it's incredible you go
and it's easy to go i got to be
responsible with this
you know it's like yeah be responsible
with the gift
the kid has that's the most kid's heart
that's the most important thing love it
because that kid's gonna be a big deal
that's a big deal kid right there should
be working here someday
i love it running a whole area
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt-free stage andrew and rachel are
with us which can only mean one thing
they're debt-free congratulations thank
you thank you steve
where do you guys live clarksville
clarksville yeah awesome thank you
absolutely welcome to nashville and how
much debt have you two paid off
two hundred thirteen fifty two thousand
dollars
yes impressive how long did this take
you two years
24 months exactly that's really
impressive
what's your range of income during this
time uh just about 125 000
combined okay we all do for a living we
own a small business up in clarksville
doing what auto repair oh good okay it's
a good business
really good business and uh so 213
thousand dollars making 125.
you sold something we sold everything
all right tell us the story what kind of
debt was this and what happened
uh we started out we had car payments
for both of us we had an rv
um wait a minute a car guy has a bunch
of car payments no
we did of course and an rv we did we did
what did those three things total oh
the truck was 50 the rv was
40. the other car was 30. yeah
okay that's what i'm thinking all right
so we we did keep one of the cars
we paid it off yeah um we do still have
it okay i sold the truck sold the rv
all right that's 90 grand of the 213.
yes yeah
all right that makes now these numbers
are starting to get where you get
because i didn't see
any there's any food in there right some
beans
yeah but you're still on rice and beans
but yeah 90 off that 213 is helping me
get there okay
all right cool so what happened what
caused all this because you went bananas
we did um we liked stuff yep
um that was that was our problem we um
nobody else does um we just wanted all
the things our
our um our hearts desires were just in
the wrong place
we thought as long as we could make the
payment we're all right and what broke
your back what made you change
uh things with the business at the end
of 18 got a little tight
um we always made sure our people were
paid well
we were the first to always take the you
know pay cut and
um we just ran out of
month we still had the money you know
money before the month was still there
too much left at the end of the month
yeah so the beginning of
uh of 19 we just hit rock bottom
and um our church right at the same time
was offering fpu
and at that point we were within 30 days
of losing our home
wow every time we heard a truck outside
we were making sure it wasn't the repo
man
whoa you were really bad yeah yeah we
yeah we got a bad
total stress yeah we we had uh we were
probably a couple days from receiving
eviction notices we were
we were there man we just uh it was it
was bottom
wow so went through fpu um immediately
started
giving joyfully and sacrificially to our
church
and um you know started our budget and
we sold a lot of stuff you went through
the house sold furniture sold
musical instruments that from high
school and college and
yeah just got rid of everything yeah how
long did it take you to get current
that's that's the crazy story so um our
church
actually loaned us a month's payment to
get out of a bad spot
within two months we were able to pay
that back and catch up
um we sold the truck um we
after we sold the truck there was an
overpayment so we got a big check in the
mail
um we got a payment back from i think
there was some gap
insurance we got several checks that
just we called it mailbox money it just
it just showed up unexpectedly god sent
us money in our mailbox and
couldn't find any money when you were
being stupid when you got smart god
started spending it yeah
and uh the money just showed up and
within two months we were completely
current on our mortgage wow
um it took us a little longer to sell
the rv um we had to put it on
consignment at a lot and that took
that took a couple months um but yeah
the truck the truck went right away
so how long in that process before
because i mean when you hit
that you got that kind of stuff bearing
down on you i've been there
yeah uh how long y'all been married
almost 10 years 10 years this year
and when you get that you got that
bearing down on you you're about to kill
each other oh yeah
kill everything in sight yeah uh the
stress level is out the
you know out your ears it's crazy and
how long before you start getting a
sense of peace a sense of control from
the time you started the class
i started feeling it pretty quickly but
it i mean it
it takes a while for it to be a reality
yeah it was it was you could see it
yeah it was probably two or three months
before we kind of started
feeling like okay there's we we got this
you know we
yeah uh probably by month three we were
seeing the like april may
of of 19. yeah it was so how did that
impact your
business you said your business was
struggling and then all of a sudden it
feels like it turned around
oh yeah our business skyrocketed um
we we had become somewhat disengaged
with our business our business was
was somewhat running on its own without
our input at times
and uh i mean we we re-engaged
we we got some some great team members i
mean we
had a lot of great team members already
but um
they they got behind us they saw what we
were doing um they rallied around us
and uh and we've um we've had a record
year 20
2020 was a record year for us so gonna
figure
out yeah through all this we we never
slowed down
yeah so what'd this do with your
marriage where was it and where is it
you want to take that one
be very careful about your answer you
have to tell the truth you're on the
radio
we have a lie detector yeah no we we had
some rough times i mean it was
definitely a roller coaster and there
were some
there were some pretty far down uh dives
in that
process but um i i can't even
begin to tell you how much stress is off
of us um
you can't believe it until you've been
there yeah
are you missing those high school uh
instruments
no because little girl locally who's in
high school who's going to grow with
them the way i did
all that junk we have shoved in corners
of our house we don't need anyway man
we actually ended up selling our house
through this process oh wow
yeah so uh we came here and we were
actually sitting right here on this
couch
and a guy called in and said should i
sell my house
to uh to pay off some debt and your
answer to him was well do you like the
house or not
and uh he liked his house so you told
him to keep his house but we
looked at ourselves and we're like we
hate our house
it wasn't a long term long-term house
you know we had planned on living in
this house for
three or four years and that was ten
years ago yeah and um
we actually worked out a deal with a
real estate agent to get some uh
kind of some some cleaning up renovation
renovations paint carpet you know stuff
like that
um we ended up selling the house for 50
000 more than we thought we were going
to get for it
and uh so we and that enters into this
numbers too then yes
yes wow so we took that uh we took that
equity in so you guys
you weren't you weren't biting around
the edges on this you walked you you ate
your way right through the middle yes
absolutely you did everything and you
did it all
big yeah go big or go home absolutely
wow
so impressive yeah thank you was it
worth it oh absolutely
yes so much why didn't i do it five
years before right yes yeah yeah that's
and now we're lined up to teach an fpu
class
coordinator so hey are the guys in your
shop
watching you walk around a little bit
taller a little bit with a little bit
lighter smile yeah for sure yeah cause
we talk about changing our family trees
but
we we can't ever forget that we're also
changing the the interactions of the
people that we were with
day in and day out yeah absolutely
rubbing elbows in the shop
yeah for sure yeah wow good for you guys
so proud of you you're just so cool i'm
so glad you're teaching fpu because
ain't anything anybody's going to bring
up no whining will be allowed
you've done everything you'll be like
shut up right
do this don't be why you cut up your
stupid cards yeah
you will be like me man i had no mercy
on people when they were in that class
yeah
wow i'm so proud of you guys thank you
well done well done all right count it
down 213
000 paid off in two years making 125
count it down let's hear a debt free
screen all right three
two one we're debt free
i love it
and just watching their body language
life is good this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run
every month you'll save even more always
use the magic word the promo code ramsey
to get the best
possible deal all right today's question
comes from steve
in kansas steve asks my wife and i
discuss our budget every two weeks but
it never goes where it's supposed to go
she always finds something to spend
money on but when i want to buy
something she shuts me down
i also cashed out a mutual fund and it
had seventy thousand dollars in it to
pay an inheritance
from an inheritance to pay down our
mortgage but she's dragging her feet on
paying it off
more of a statement than a question yeah
you know whenever i hear this dave i
this is never about a budget for me
i always think this is about
um relational power right there's some
either she's self-soothing with this or
he's writing this in trying to you know
feeling like the hero a little bit but
this is the only
play she's got in this marriage only
place she can be heard or
i guess somebody can just be a jerk but
whenever somebody says we talk about
this stuff a lot
man you can talk circles around things
unless but if you're not talking towards
something
it's a waste of a conversation right
yeah the the illusion about
communication is is that it has actually
happened
right we said a lot of words and so we
parted ways
what i what i run into with this is a
kind of nerd or free spirit thing
i'll give you a guess i'm going to read
some mail here read between the lines
i'm going to guess and say steve
is the nerd he is a uh
uh
and she is the free spirit
and to steve when you write it down and
we all agree to it
in his mind it was chiseled in stone by
god and he brought it back from mount
sinai
right you know and he's like god says
this it's in stone this is not only a
contract you will be struck by lightning
if you violate the contract
right a wee bit parasitical right a wee
bit
uptight right her on the other hand
she's still functioning at a freaking
eight-year-old level
and just did he bops into life and did
he bops out and looks at her husband's
thing says yeah babe let's do it and
then wanders off and doesn't anymore
make a contract
then fly to the moon and she little does
she know she just signed up
with a contract with big boy contract
but a budget is a
is a is it directional right it should
be a contract
right but it should not be an uptight
contract and what's the problem steve is
is she does not view it the way you view
it she doesn't think she's breaking her
word
and you think that she's a liar and it'd
be cut
right and it becomes about who's got the
strength here
yeah in his language i also cashed out
this mutual fund now i'm i'm
i'm taking what uh she's gonna take that
power i'm gonna take this one and now
man you are no the only thing that
happens here is what what you've gotta
do is you have to raise the level of the
language to communicate and go okay
honey
when i say this it means to me we are
pinky swear spit shake we are you know
cutting our little hand here putting a
little blood on there we're signing an
oath in blood that this is by god what
we're going to do
and i want to ask her what is it and if
you sign this
if you say yes i agree to this that's to
me what you are doing
so when you don't do these things honey
it makes me feel like you are lying
and she needs to go whoa i had no idea i
was signing up for that trip
and i then i want to ask her why are you
unwilling to unable to lock arms with
this guy and stick to what you said you
were going to do
because she's not even in the same
ballpark she just drove off and did
whatever the crap she wanted to do
but look at him they're both violating
but what amounts to is they didn't have
the same
language to say this is a contract and
they don't have the same destinations
where they're headed
yeah but well they both looked at it and
they all said yeah let's go to florida
but he meant he meant that in the
morning and she met next year
or she meant it'll work out yeah we'll
get there eventually we'll get there
and this is no where is the car packed
why aren't you in the car his response
well then i want to buy something yeah
well that's just hit back that's
just childish [ __ ] back yeah yeah and um
there's just an overall
machine you know in other words if i'm
this this inheritance thing is an
emotional thing to him
and it should be that's a valid thing if
he says
i'm gonna take my mama's money and put
it on the mortgage
that's a big deal to me so when i put
this money in the account
and by the way steve why didn't you just
write the freaking check why are you
waiting on her to do it
uh but anyway aside from that uh it's
straight into the mortgage
right you know it's like but she's
dragging her feet why is she dragging
her feet just
write the dadgum check you said you were
gonna do it or did we have a
conversation
about hey we got this inheritance let's
talk through what we're gonna do with it
we all agreed
yeah right did we have that conversation
did steve with his math
and his uh excel sheets create his old
universe here
i i i got to tell you the reason i know
this stuff is exactly the mistakes i
made
it's because i'm the spreadsheet guy i'm
the decisive guy
and to me by god when you say you're
gonna do something that's just like you
said you're gonna do it so why aren't
you doing it
i can't stand it we're the reverse in my
house and sharon's like well i didn't
really
mean i was like gonna you know sell one
of the kids i mean and now you got one
of the kids up for sale you know it's
like
well seventy thousand like let's we're
gonna play with five
and so sixty five thousand is great
right well sort of a minute but i didn't
exactly mean it you know and so we've
had to go oh look okay
we are completely agreeing on this date
this amount
this is the thing and you get a vote and
i get a vote
do you feel heard yes i feel heard
then by god you're gonna stick to your
word okay
i mean we've had to have these type of
real clear
words in our com visceral words in our
communication early on
to get where we're locked in because now
she i mean
to me once you say it's not if for nerds
if it's on the spreadsheet it's law
it's just that's law and for free
spirits like me it's it's an
approximation yeah i always get there
yeah that's a good general concept i
like that you have a spreadsheet we're
all going to be 50 someday right
yeah we're going to get there yeah it's
a
it's what they're saying and she didn't
sign it
actually she signed it in his mind but
she didn't know it
that's my point that's what i'm saying
and i think that's a great
exercise for every married couple to say
we've got to be in agreement we've got
to be in unity and you're going to use
different languages rachel's book know
yourself know your money he's got
tons of stuff in there about how your
spouse is viewing this
conversation about money and how you're
viewing the conversation about money and
it comes from all these different angles
know yourself know your money and it's
just it's so powerful
yeah and i as the free spirit there's
this i always
come back to this thing about control
yeah this
power this what do you mean i can't i'm
in this house and i'm in
and that's me being immature that's what
it comes down to no i mean
because the flow of money is about
control
but what you have to fight to do in this
communication is
uh relinquish half of the control
like sharon and i at this moment are in
this dispute
over a large purchase and we talked
about it before i walked out of the
house this morning
okay because we have a rule when when
we're not both on the page we don't do
it
until we both get there we don't do it
whether it's a large gift
on you know philanthropy we're giving
whether it's a major move down here at
the office with a bunch of money or
something like that or whether it's a
purchase and in this case it's a
purchase
of something we're looking at that we're
but but she's like well i think we just
you got the money what's wrong with you
you just need to do this and i'm like
nope not ready
this is not right it doesn't feel right
it's just not the same one so you both
have a veto card
you both can play the the trump card if
you've ever played you know hand of
cards where you can play a trump card
i'm not talking about donald i'm talking
about the joker game okay
i'm not talking about the joker i'm
talking about a trump card so
but the the you know you've got you both
have a vote that can call it
and so what we do is it forces us to do
nothing
until we can find the thing that we both
can agree to where you align
and that means you have patience
intentionality and a tone we
value grace we value the unity more than
we value the thing
how long did that take to get to uh 10
years
a minute 10 years yeah after going broke
you know
first thing we did is try to kill each
other when we're going broke right like
we're talking about with a couple on
that debt-free screen but
you know that this is vital stuff right
here y'all
because all the data points that we have
in our millionaire study that ramsay did
gives you very clear guidelines
that very few people become millionaires
uh
without spousal participation and
spousal unity you got to be alive and
spout
in spite of these communication
breakdowns you just don't do it you do
it
because you force these conversations at
a real healthy level
that's why dr john deloney is here
because he can talk about this stuff
intelligently this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality and host of
the dr john deloney show
is my co-host today as we talk about
your life
and that is what he specializes in and
your money and of course we'll both talk
to you about that
open phones here as we mix those two
things together and create this soup
called common sense
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five clint starts off this
hour in chattanooga
hey clint how are you i'm doing well how
are you dave better than i deserve
for sure how can i help uh my wife and i
are 37 years old
um we've been living your plan uh since
we graduated college
and got to baby step 7 in 2015 so we
haven't had payments
in six years at this point um
wow yeah so you just dropped that so
yeah so you're like
32 years old you had a paid for house
and you've been sitting there five years
since then so are you a millionaire
already
uh yes we are at 37 years old because
you did our plan since college touchdown
i'm done
john you just take the show from here
i'm out i just felt the collective uh
eyes of america roll like oh gosh this
guy
this guy that's awesome clint you're
incredible brother
well thank you very much it's uh it's
been a great journey for sure
how can we help today so um we have a
great problem of having a lot of money
in retirement accounts already i hate it
um
so we've got about 515 000 in retirement
um and my question is should we keep
adding into that retirement or should i
redirect
that return leave what's in there there
and redirect future contributions into
something
that's not a retirement account that's
locked down until 59 and a half
what's your household income last year
we made 225 yeah i would probably
not i probably would because of your
young age
here's your trade-off okay your
trade-off is
like your concern on one side of the
pendulum is everything stuck in return
until 59 i can't mess with
it and i can't do something else with it
i want to like buy a lake house or
something
right and which is an important purchase
and uh uh so the uh
that that's the trade-off the other side
of the pendulum is every dollar we do
something else with the government's
gonna get more of it
right and so if you take for instance
i'll tell you what i do i max out
everything
and then any other savings i do for
other things i just throw it in an index
fund like an s p 500 index fund
uh it doesn't have any taxes on it until
you sell it because most because it's a
low turnover ratio
uh and if you keep it if you leave the
money in there at least a year what
taxes you have on the growth will be at
15
at capital gains anyway in your case my
case i make more than that so i get
charged more for capital gains because
i'm an evil rich person you must be
punished in america
but um the uh um
so yeah you get taxed lower and
you've got access to it but it's still
not as tax
friendly as retirement is right so if
you want to divert a portion of this
over to that that's fine the trade-off
is not you're going to be broke at
retirement the trade-off is
the government's going to get more of
your money doing that
in order to have access to it before 59
and a half
okay great and i think that's a
reasonable trade-off for some
of your investments at this stage so
here's a rule of thumb
if that money's invested and making
around 10
if it's in good mutual funds the way we
teach it should be doing that
on average it's gonna if you don't add
anything else to it it's going to double
about every seven years
so at 44 it's going to be a million
at 51 it's going to be 2 million
at 58 it's going to be 4 million
if you add nothing to it right
and all i was doing is doubling it each
time you follow me and so when you
and so if you have 4 million in your
protected accounts
and that's all you have in there that's
fine
uh if you as long as you've got some
other wealth built on the side and we're
not talking about consuming the money
but you're not consuming anything
because you're doing
you're consuming things but you're doing
it intentionally and you're not asking
me about that you're asking me about
investing
that's correct yeah so oh man you're so
cool that's awesome
so proud of you really nice yeah so i
probably would not shut it down
completely but i would redirect
some of to where you've got some money
over
i'd like for you to have if you got four
or five six million
seven million in retirement i'd like for
you to have three or four million
at 58 in non-retirement okay great
and that you could do other stuff with
in the meantime again
it could be a purchase it could be just
access to the money without any
penalties it could you know
because you have got you've gotten such
a head start god you're so
amazing so when you're when you're
thinking about buying a big piece of
real estate
yeah do you use that index fund
that's my savings savings account that's
my savings account okay that's exactly
what i'm doing
and so if um you know like we're
building these buildings here
and so what i do is i take all my income
right now
almost all of it i live on a little bit
of it but i throw almost all of it in an
index fund
and then when i have to write these
thinking checks for this concrete we're
putting up next door
and getting ready to start an event
center across the street this millions
and millions of dollars they just come
out of that account
gotcha and it's just it's just parked
there sometimes i don't make a lot on it
because sometimes the market's up or
down while i ride it but i can afford
that ride
in that situation because there's so
many freaking zeros involved is the
is the volatility worth just putting it
in the
i guess you can't put in a savings
account because it's not insured yeah
you're going well
it's not insured but i'm not worried
about the insurance it's just it might
it might lose one percent
it might make ten percent okay but if
you put in the other you're gonna make
one percent
and i'm just not gonna be thrilled okay
you know so i've got some
sitting in in money markets and that
kind of stuff for that kind of thing but
i'm just generally this is an investment
account i'm throwing it in there i try
to leave it alone a year
so i can get the lower tax rate because
even i get a capital gains tax break
on that but but this is baby step seven
stuff folks
that's what you're doing at baby step
seven and this is what you're doing if
you're 37 and you're already a
millionaire
and these are good problems to figure
out yeah this is muslims this is um
when i started this show i dreamed i
would get that call someday
that 20 years after doing this that guy
when he was 22
started doing this stuff he's 37 now and
that's where he is that's
he's why we're here that's who i want to
be with man that's awesome
jew i love it love it love it love it
love it love it love it very cool stuff
yeah so yeah the thing you don't want to
you guys listening you don't want to use
that discussion that we're having there
as anything except something to point
out that i want to be someday
it's not a discussion to say that's a
reason to not do the baby steps
well i've even wondered if i'm saving to
buy a
rental property if i'm saving to buy
like some acreage or something that
would be after your house was paid off
right so you're in baby step seven right
yeah where do i hold that and so you're
just going to dump it in next year
you can you could hold it into that
index fund but the risk you're taking is
the market could go down
um which means you would just if you
found a piece of ground you might not
want to buy it because your mar your
money's worth less right then you may
want to wait and come up and then you
might miss a piece of ground so
or you might go well it's just the cost
of doing business and i lost a little
bit
you're never going to lose the whole
account if you do that means the entire
economy collapsed and that's just not
going to happen i'm not
i'm not worried about that uh does it
dive sometimes and take your breath away
yeah and does it shoot up sometimes and
take your breath away yeah that's
part of the part of the roller coaster
ride that's why people get on them
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
john there is a disturbing
thing happening with teenagers and with
covid that you've been talking about on
your show and james our producer sent us
a
an article on the loneliness issue
and teen mental health with this
that is it's scary yeah if you if you
could construct a way to torture
teenagers it would be to isolate them
put them in a house with their family
for a year
or more and force them to connect
via social media which are outlets that
we know
exacerbate anxiety depression these
things make people feel less than make
people
just accelerate this disconnection man
and it's it's an
absolute mess dave it's a mess
so the kids not being back in the
classroom is just
is causing uh uh well i mean we're
seeing
suicides increase we're seeing
loneliness increase we're seeing
just because the development human
development requires interaction
with other humans and it's not and
social media is not interaction
no and especially especially with kids
especially with
with teenagers in middle school we they
are figuring out who they are
in relationship with other people and
when you take that off it is just like
cutting the string on a balloon and it's
off right
there's just no way to ground when it's
just you and a screen
and then you just you go through these
curated images of
what other people are supposedly doing
what their lives are supposedly like and
it makes you feel less than and more
isolated more isolated more isolated
well
and then people have digital courage and
so they become bullies
and mean and other stuff here's another
interesting thing when you and i were
kids
and we ran into a real bully or we are
one ourselves and we
somebody mouthed off to us that hurt
and then we went about our day and with
our friends and
there's just a natural cycle to that
when it's in black and white
text it stays you read over and over and
you go back to it you go back to it and
it re-injures and re-injures that's
another thing
if you lose lost a grandparent from uh
so you've got a generation that wasn't
connected enough
with humans as it was but on top of that
you just took them completely and stuck
them in a house that's right
with covid and then they're not going
back to the classroom
and so the teachers unions are screwing
these kids man there's
i just can't um i can't find the data
the science that supports keeping these
kids by themselves
um even our kid has been back um
in a regular public school they got to
wear masks into these things but
but man he gets to interact with their
kids and he gets to be around other kids
he's got
gets to run around and these they're
they're making up new game but there's
with other people um and i'm i'm
hearing stories about um reading stories
about teachers unions trying to
say yeah we'll let them back but why
we're going to replace the air
conditioning complexes or we've got to
fill in the blank and using these
moments
to try to get other gains for the
teachers man my wife's a teacher i'm
from teachers i've been a teacher i'm
all about teachers but
it's all about these kids it is about
these kids at the end of the day that's
why we are teachers that's why i was a
teacher my wife's teacher
because we're about these kids and these
kids are dying on the vine dave it's
really it's it every mental health
professional i know
is predicting a just a collapse of these
kids when they go back
um because they've just been separate
for so long and it's just a mess you
know
one of the things we've talked about and
the data is there it's been there for
years i remember reading it a long time
ago and then you reminded me of it the
other day
that um teens need
uh physical proximity to
figure out who they are right and they
even
the the thing it's if you've never heard
this before it's going to sound strange
to you but
your even their heartbeats start to they
they regulate all of them
yeah their eyes they hit each other
you know they they not only pick up the
same words and vernacular and those
kinds of things but literally
the physiology of their bodies is into
it has to be with other tend to connect
yes and when you don't have that it's
not developing properly it's
that's exactly right and you you don't
get that
that teacher that just puts that hand on
the shoulder
that just winks at the kid in the
hallway we used to call it accidental
community
where you as a teacher you just watch
for that one kid who's got his heads
down
who's not getting it at home who's not
getting it who's getting beat up by his
older brother who's struggling on the
bus whatever the thing is
and it's those little touch points that
a teacher can provide that that school
counselor that school principal that
coach can probably
not the academics no it's the relational
quality yes
yeah yeah you can get socialization we
can transfer information that's that's
the easy part
it's talking to the teacher that's
that's showing you
man you should see my son coming home
from history he is learning the
narrative these stories
and they've come alive and he's asking
questions at home that i never dreamed a
10 year old
that's because he's got a relationship
with somebody that he trusts
who's giving him this information right
and and he could read a book
it would go in one ear and not the other
but this teacher is helping to come
alive in him right and so all it to say
is man
where you can find ways to let your kids
be around other kids find ways to
connect with your kids
find ways to get them out with other
children this is
far more dangerous than the virus
i think it is that's a statement i made
yeah i i can't see a way that it's not
dave
um i i have not seen been compelled by
the data on kids
yeah i mean the first time i heard you
um talk was uh
uh you you talked about screens
before covid before coving i mean i
don't know three four years ago i heard
you do a talk
and you were talking about the damage uh
not necessarily from the bullying the
bullying's part of it but not
necessarily from that but the damage
that this lack of physical proximity
to create socialization and proper
development
in a child seven to eighteen
seven to twenty seven years old think of
it this way we
you know depending on what stats you
read is seventy to ninety percent of
communication is non-verbal
right and so when you export all of your
interaction with somebody to
zeros and ones to text messages you're
you're communicating 20 30
you're missing shoulder movement and
body posture and eye crinkles
and this syncing up that we do together
right
so yeah i have not seen any data that
said kids don't need to be back in
schools
that covets just wiping out kids in fact
it's been the opposite it's taken out
folks who are
older who are um not in good health
right who
have other things going on now of course
there's the outliers we hear about
are you seeing the mental health
community starting to raise this banner
i've they've been doing it for a year
all along all along
they weren't getting a platform you
can't there is no platform and everyone
is so busy
throwing things up online just so they
could see folks right
because they knew this crisis was going
to emerge and this the other thing think
about
um if you had someone that you love your
grandparent died in a car wreck
the last thing you're going to do is go
watch anything that has to do with car
wrecks until you're until you heal
and if your grandparent passed away from
covet or you have someone you love pass
away from covet
every news story every everything's
about covent cove cove so these kids are
just
looping on this all day long all day
long all day long
and those loops just become that anxiety
when you can't take that anxiety more
that's when that that weight just takes
over you that's when you just sit back
and you fade back and we call that
depression that's what you just unplug
from
from the world man and we're just what
we're just watching it happen with kid
after kid after kid after kid and at
some point
whether you got to run around and play
outside i don't care how you have to do
it
you got to get your kids in proximity
other kids
you have to dave even when it comes to
church the bible says don't forsake the
gathering
of the believers figure it out i've
heard of churches meeting in people's
backyard and whatever you got to do you
need to be in proximity
figurative human beings right human
beings need relationship
to function properly got to it is not
good
that man be alone and uh
this is what we're seeing and we're
seeing this in careers we're seeing it
in businesses
uh we're seeing it with this article uh
what was this article out of
psychology today psychology today on the
loneliness and depression
and suicide rate of teens yeah it's
really tough man
um and even this let's say you're in a
city in a town where you just can't or
you live in a
highly compressed city
that means you're gonna have to go over
the top being engaged with your kid
yeah you're gonna have to put your
electronics away moms and dads and
you're gonna have to plug in you're
gonna have to figure out how to kick a
soccer ball in your living room you have
to do some first 30 days binge watching
netflix was okay it's over it's not okay
now it's not okay anymore these screens
are killing you find ways to engage in
your kids
dr john dolone ramsey personality i am
dave ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the debt free stage in the ramsey
solutions lobby
jeremy is with us hey jeremy how are you
pretty good dave
awesome man good to have you so you're
here because you're debt-free how much
did you pay off uh i'd rather tell you
seventy-two thousand and forty-two
dollars
wow how long did this take uh 22 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time uh
started about 35 000 and last year i
made 49.
good what you do for a living uh piano
teacher good for you how'd you raise
your income that much
uh in 2018 i started a job at a
preschool as a journal music teacher
and i used all of that income to pay
down the mortgage
i was doing triple mortgage payments
i'll show it's your extra job
yeah i was working 65 to 70 hours a week
i got you okay so you paid off your
house
yes wow i love it piano teacher way to
go
it's the only dead i had the only death
i've really ever had wow
man look at you man and with you say a
piano teacher for preschoolers
no that was his own job and then the
extra job was at a preschool yeah
very cool what's the house worth uh
zillow says about 204
i bought it for 105. where do you live
uh south elgin illinois
uh just west of chicago okay wow
good for you man congratulations okay
so two years ago
ding ding you go i'm gonna go crazy and
pay off my house
fast what happened what caused that uh i
was working
i was a little bit underemployed before
i started the job at the preschool so it
was a
big boost of income and i decided i'm
not going to work 65 to 70 hours
for the next 20 years so if i get the
house out of the way i can cut my hours
down
but i didn't want to give up my business
of piano lessons so
um you may be with a piano teacher
and a a preschool teacher you may be one
of the top two or three most patient men
in america
you've got no idea wow yeah you're like
a walking xanax i think
probably yeah what a gift of humanity
you are good for you
man that's fabulous okay so how'd you
run into us
uh i started listening in 2009 a friend
of mine turned me onto the show
at the time i was 27 making 19 000 a
year
and so now i'm up to like 45 ish a year
so you know
yeah but as you're going along two years
ago you went i think i can do this dave
should i finish off the house it was
starting the job that did it because i
couldn't
possibly at 32 000 or whatever i was
making
uh before the job the second job i
couldn't possibly do much extra yeah so
but then you said
i think i'm going to throw some math at
this ding ding oh yeah yeah yeah
i wouldn't say yeah yeah now i'm doing
30
into retirement investing so uh i'll be
all set now
yeah yeah how old are you uh 38. way to
go man
single never married no kids if you're
gonna put my phone number in the bottom
of the screen that would be uh
that'd be fine available and debt-free
baby step seven
you know this should be a t-shirt that's
right baby step 7 and available
yeah yeah yeah and super patient
true enough wow possibly a saint
[Laughter]
i'm just saying all of you jeremy i'm
way to go man all right so
when someone asks you you're a teacher
you like to teach obviously
when someone asks you how do you do this
what do you tell them
i always thought about tomorrow my
tomorrow needs to be better than today
um and i was raised by my uh
parents and my grandparents instilled
always think about the future my
grandfather owned a business
and that's kind of what planted it you
know when i started listening to dave i
never had a lot of
i didn't have any debt when i started
listening i started in baby step four
which is like oh where am i i'm in four
all right i'm doing pretty good
um and i just wanted to not have to
work so hard in my job when the phone
rings it could be a terrible phone call
or a great phone call and i over time
the more money i build the more wealth i
build the less chance of it being
a terrible phone call you know the
longer i go i can enjoy my work rather
than
stress about losing it which covet
didn't help
yeah i i lost almost all the income in
covid
so thankfully uh almost all of my
customers stuck with me yeah but uh
i had four uh streams of income and all
of them
gone yeah so they're all back now uh no
just the piano lessons oh that's [ __ ]
and then i had to drive
uber eats the last year to make up the
difference okay i was doing
30 some hours on that on top of the
piano lessons because once you got a
goal
oh you gotta go i i said when i first
started the preschool i did the math on
your website the mortgage calculator to
see
when can i go see dave and it said
payoff december 2020. so i'm like
coveted like oh come on you know so
that's why i
cranked up the ubereats i'm like i am
not going to let this go yeah
and you're still here in early 21st well
done yeah i know yeah
yeah excellent job dude very good
how's it feel great yeah i the future is
just
uphill from here no payment in the world
nope nope
totally weird shoveling so much at
investments every single uh
month it's great how much peace
and healing are you seeing as these kids
come back and can sit with you at the
piano it's great
uh me being a one person in their house
it's a normal thing for them i'm getting
a lot of customers like that that
it's everything else is weird but i can
be normal well i am weird but you know
yeah but you being there
yeah yeah that's cool very cool man well
done
very well done yeah so all the 30 hours
and the uber eats was it worth it
oh yeah um it was long but at least i
knew
that it was for a goal i wasn't throwing
it out the window it wasn't forever
no yeah it's not a way of life yeah i do
the math i should be able to fully
retire at my current level
about 54 if i keep shoveling at
investments like this
yeah so somebody is driving down the
road right now they're making 45
000 a year and they got 70 grand in
whatever debt
what do you tell them just keep at it
you know think about um
you know the future don't worry about
today as much but
be you know plan for tomorrow that's the
big one um you don't want to be i know
people
that are retirement age that have
nothing you know and i am determined not
to be that
yeah yeah well nobody plans to do that
that's true uh they do that by not
planning
so um yeah you don't nobody says i'm
going to fail on purpose
let's do let's get about the business of
failing no we don't do that
so well done i just got to tell you i
mean just your whole spirit
i wish y'all could be in here there's
something about you that i can tell
you're a great teacher i can tell you
love
interacting people but you're an
encouragement to me today i'm grateful
for you man this is such a cool story
and it's just life kept throwing you a
lemon after lemon after lemon and you
were like i'm just gonna drink more
lemonade and more lemonade more lemonade
a year ago i was a wreck because i
thought it was all gone you know oh boy
but you know i mean he's got back off
the couch he figured it out yeah i had
to there's nothing more
rewarding more fulfilling than getting
out of the house and going to work
yeah you know oh boy sitting at home
solves a multitude of sins
vital hands the devil's workshop well
done sir well done
all right jeremy we got a copy of rachel
cruz's best-selling book new york times
bestseller
know yourself know your money to say
congratulations oh thank you
jeremy 72 000
paid off that's his house and everything
30. seven years old oh and he's
available 22 months he did this
i'm making 35 to 49. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one i'm debt-free
baby this is how it's done
i i've threatened to open up our own
version of eharmony for years and i
guess i'm gonna have to do it i'm
telling you
that dave math will hunt right there
that'll be good
i just it's it's just one story after
another dave
and i've only been doing this a year
every one of these i just think it gives
me
i drive home people are inspiring a
little bit lighter
people are inspiring what they can do
when they believe
they can hope is a powerful drug it is
and he's like okay i got knocked off
that horse so i'm going to do hebrew
each and then i got knocked off that
horse and i'm going to
and i'm freaking out but i'm going to go
i'm just going to leave home and go work
and
and this is how you do it right here
it's exciting every day you got to
choose again and choose again and choose
ding ding ding little wins what i want
accidentally wins the super bowl what a
stud man
well done sir this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five david's with us
in kansas city hi david how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up uh well i wanted to
thank you guys for taking my calls and i
just talked to you dave
hey john you too all right
um so i am a registered nurse i've been
working
for a lot of the code with pandemic i
make about
55 to 80 maybe 85
thousand a year depending on how much i
work
i owe 105 or so on my house i bought it
in 2019
is valued at 165.
i'm in school right now
and when i graduate i'm hoping to make
anywhere from between 90 to 140
what will your degree what are you
usually advancing your nursing career
yeah so i'm going to be a nurse
practitioner okay good very good
um when will you graduate in december
okay good so this year okay yeah uh i
have a wife and a kid
uh he's two and a half and i have
another one to do in april
so she just stopped working as a nanny
and
is a stay-at-home mom now cool
the schools in
the outskirts of kansas city missouri
where i am right now
are not great and i'm not too excited
about
growing up in this area sending my kid
to school that
at one point wasn't even accredited
and justice are not as good as the
schools over on the kansas side that are
top 15 in the country but the houses in
that area
that i'd be wanting to buy by keeping up
with the joneses house
that i'd eventually like to move into
are like 400 000
or so so i'm trying to figure out
do i no i don't mind sending him to
those schools
now when he's young but i don't want to
send him there when he's he's two and a
half he's not in school
no but he will be well yeah in four
years
five ten years yeah i mean in four years
you'll have your
your nurse practitioner you're gonna be
making a lot more money move
yeah so my question is should i
uh take the next three four years
and pay off this house and then save up
cash
yes to buy uh the house before i move
yeah that'd be fine or or just save up
enough cash that you can make the move
and then pay off that house
shortly after that hey david listen
david
four years ago i was two states and
three jobs from where i am right now
and if you had told me i was gonna be
working on a radio station next to this
guy
i would have laughed at you okay
so yeah carry on man and i i i get when
you have this second kid and you start
wanting to make plans and make sure
everything's gonna be mapped out
i can tell you one thing about having
kids is you can't map out anything man
it just comes you can do your best you
can and you gotta plan right but don't
don't don't there's no downside to
paying off this house and piling up cash
right that'll give you options when
you're ready to make your move but you
don't have to sit and fret about it
today you're going to steal joy from
right now
worrying about something four years from
now brother and you may be two states
and three jobs from where you are right
now
exactly okay exactly love the fact that
you have a new one on the way
be excited about it live in it can't
just pile up cash knowing that someday
we're going to move
yeah and that there's just no downside
to that and then you can
either pay cash or almost pay cash and
then pay that house off later either one
will work
all of that's going to work out for you
just fine
if you uh don't understand something
don't buy it and that includes real
estate right now a lot of real estate
questions coming in a lot of real estate
discussion out there everybody around
the water cooler is talking about real
estate you can make a six figure mistake
get educated before you buy start by
checking out our new 13 step
home buying checklist you'll learn about
every step in the buying process
from saving a down payment to closing
day plus you'll get pro tips on how to
make smart money decisions
text home checklist no spaces
home checklist 233 789 it's free
home checklist to 33 789.
shay's in houston hi shea welcome to the
ramsay show
hello um can y'all hear me sure what's
up
okay hey dave so glad to finally meet
you um
so my question is i'm 30 years old
i started your plan in 2017
single mother of two kids by trade i'm
an rn
and so in 2020 i went to zellington took
advantage of the covet
thing quit working full-time started
travel nursing
so my income went from 85
to almost 300 000 last year
i grew up i grew up super i grew up
super freaking poor like and it's just
me and my boys
you know left a toxic family environment
yada yada
so anyways i have been holding money
because i was
scared that crap you know
like if i pay this off my credit score
is going to go down so
basically i started out with almost 83
000 worth of debt
and i have 42 000 left and it's only
student loans left to pay
well when i paid my car off my credit
score
went down i kind of i kind of skipped
i'm not really skipped but i've got the
three to six months
obviously saved but i'm so you're doing
your point
because you're working your plan
and well you can't modify my plan and
call it my plan it's your plan
okay you're sitting in a situation where
the doctor tells the patient
do these three things the patient goes
i'm going to do two of them
and they come back two weeks later and
that infection is now the size of a
softball and you're like what did you do
and you're like well i only did two of
the three take that dumb medicine
really quick though i've got 56 000 in
my savings yeah
so i was like really quick how much debt
have you got
forty two thousand dollars left so
you're debt free by the time we get off
the phone call what's the problem
i know but i'm scared i won't be able to
get me and my boys a house
why no without without you oh you mean
without a credit score
yeah okay well just make sure all of
your accounts are closed
and all of them have a zero balance so
that you actually do have a credit score
not just a low credit score
okay because there's only two ways you
can get a house a high credit score or
no credit score you can't get it with a
low credit score
okay so you want to make sure you have
nothing to do nothing open
everything needs to be closed and zero
balance
no outstanding bad debt so that it does
go to zero because if you go to a
mortgage company like churchill mortgage
and you say i have a zero credit score
they can walk through what a process
called manual underwriting and get you a
house the same exact price as you would
have gotten
if you had a 746 credit score okay
okay they can do that okay but
they can't do it with a 576.
because that's where i'm at right now
because everything's paid off but it's
just
like my credit cards are just you know
they're opening there but
they're still open yeah close them yeah
and zero balance
everything and six months later you'll
have a zero score
okay i'm gonna do it pull up your credit
bureau report
pull up your credit bureau report and
anything that's on there
make sure that account is zeroed and
closed by friday
hey listen to me listen two things
number one at the end of at end of
business today
you are free you got it
i want you to hear that word in your
soul i'm not gonna hoard it i'm gonna
i'm gonna do it hey here's the second
thing yeah you are not what happened to
you as a kid
you are creating a new legacy for those
boys their story is not gonna be your
story you're a freaking
thousand dollars you're a rock star
you are h-town's finest you've done it
you turned the corner on them
don't get held back by those old stories
that are going to continue to
try to weasel their way into your heart
they're definitely listen if somebody
says if somebody says
you forgot your raisin yup let's go i
don't eat raisins
well i'm so glad i freaking met you and
i want to send a shout out to my friend
mitch because he's the one who told me
to call
well we're so glad for nick and so glad
for you yes 300
000 a year what a stun
yeah woman yeah that's a single mom
get it i love it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit daveramsey.com
show and register we would love for you
to come to nashville and tell your story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money my co-host today is dr
john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author he is host of the
dr john delony show where he talks about
life and boundaries and relationships
and all kinds of issues having to do
with mental health
so uh hey if you want to join him on
that show you can always do that it's
a very popular podcast and youtube show
and you can call in at any time you want
just call at 844-693-3291 or you can
email him at ask
john ramsey solutions dot com
ask john ramsey solutions dot com so if
you can't get in today to talk to him
that's what you would do the phone
number though today is triple eight
eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five rob is in atlanta
georgia hey rob welcome to the ramsay
show
good afternoon dave dr v how are you
guys great man what's up
great i am calling to see when and if
i need to move from just a standard will
to like a
living revocable trust when you got 50
million or more
all right perfect easy piece yeah here's
here's why
okay these things are sold it's about a
3 500 to a 5
000 legal bill to build that document
and then you have to shift every single
thing
you own that you want to transfer at
your death which is every single thing
you own
into the name of that trust and you have
to conduct
all business in that trust
and so if you buy a car it's in that
trust if you have an investment account
it's in that trust if you own a
piece of property it's in that trust you
get ready to sell it trustee has to sign
all the documents it's a pain
in the butt to operate out of the thing
and here's what happens lawyers sell
these things all the time
as a way to avoid probate tax and as a
way to ensure that your assets are
passed the way that they're supposed to
be passed
and then they don't coach you on moving
all your freaking assets
which means the trust is sitting there's
a shell unfunded doesn't have anything
in the name of the trust and so it's of
absolutely zero value at that point
and 78 of the trusts never get funded
people don't move their assets into the
name of the trust so the whole thing's
dumber than crap
now now when you get big money big money
like i'm talking about
like like this particular building i'm
sitting in is in one of those trusts
okay now what that does then because
this building that i'm sitting in is
worth about 140 million dollars
okay so that building as it goes up
in value i don't want that value in my
estate
i want that value to pass to the kids
with no estate taxes
and so placing this puppy and operating
it out of a revocable trust makes sense
doing that for something that's a
million bucks will drive you freaking
nuts
right you follow me life insurance yes
life insurance beneficiaries and all
that stuff and
401k stuff life insurance beneficiaries
are not taxable as an estate item
anyway they're not part of your estate
technically
you know i'm just saying if if that
moves that'll move relatively quickly
after my passing
oh easy someone's name beneficiary yeah
they'll get that money
and most the time within a few weeks
they'll get your
you know and the access if you've named
the beneficiary on your 401ks and your
iras and that kind of stuff
that's going to be very easy to access
by the airs as well
and um so yeah and if you've got a
decent will that's done
your t your family ought to have access
to the executor to the cash that's in
your checking account within a matter of
days
right so the probate action will move
relatively
quickly as well assuming you have a
freaking will that's done right
and the judge doesn't have to blink at
it but you just go in
you know your lawyer dance before the
judge and do two twirls and walk out of
there with
you the executor's in charge of
everything
it doesn't drag out for months now the
the reason a lot of people do this some
states have a big
state probate tax where they they tax
your estate
upon your death like say you had five
million bucks okay and there's if
there's a three and a half percent tax
on that
then you know that's going to be a
150 000 tax what okay
on your estate and that's a state tax i
didn't know that existed
yeah it doesn't in tennessee it didn't
work
but a lot of states like florida's got a
big one so uh which bunch of old people
there so it makes sense but you know
but uh but you know that that's that's
what they're after so
the federal estate tax doesn't come into
play much because it's large the
exemptions are large enough
but that's why people move stuff into
this because you can avoid
that estate tax that probate tax
and it you know you have instantaneous
access to stuff but the problem is the
day-to-day operations while you're
living
are a complete pain in the butt and
people forget to move everything into
the name of the trust
and then operate the name of the trust
and so like we're adding some property
to this campus
and i've got to make sure all that stays
in that same trust and the money
used to buy it has to come out of this
trust right and so it's just
she's a freaking barrel fish hooks just
to keep the government's hands off the
stuff you've already paid taxes you just
blew my mind
by telling me that some states charge
you to die oh well the federal
government will too
yeah like big okay so i did not
know that yeah well yeah i mean the
federal state tax exemption right now
you just
die right yeah this is this is when you
get pissed off about taxes
and this one you get pissed off about
people saying when you work your whole
life and you started with nothing
and you work your whole life and you've
got some money and then people go well
you know the rich need to be taxed and
so when they die
they should be taxed again on money
they've already paid taxes on
so the federal estate tax exemption
right now i'm trying to look at my cheat
sheet here because it moves all the time
last year was 11 million in some change
okay
so anything over that's taxed at about
40 percent
by the feds so if you got a 20 million
dollar
21 million taxes when you got a 21
million net worth and you die you have a
4 million
tax bill even if it's all in real estate
so if it's a family ranch
you got to sell off part of the ranch to
pay the tax to pay the feds
but what about because you're an evil
rich person you already
bought that so you already made that
money so they already taxed you at 40
percent the first time
yeah this is the 80 tax off your money
death tax
yeah and that's what he's trying to
avoid that's the problem here so it's a
it's a
i did not know you just blew my mind
it's a rare moment when i'm speechless
and i don't
know wow well i it just doesn't come up
because
it's the rich or easy target right it's
you should always make fun of and steal
from the rich it's
robin hood thing and uh very democratic
thing to do
so wow i didn't know you got text when
texts when you died yeah yeah most
people don't because most people don't
have a million dollars yeah
so there's no federal tax on anything
under 11 million so you're okay
if that's the case and if you're in a
state where there's no probate tax you
don't if you don't have any money
you don't get taxed on either that's so
but if you work your whole life starting
from nothing
your grandpa started a business he tries
to hand it to your dad and then your dad
tries to hand it to you and every time
it's gone up in value
every time somebody dies it gets hit
again unless you use one of these trust
mechanisms
and even then there's some of it's going
to be exposed i think after today i'm
going to call into my own show to
process
this i don't even know what i'm saying
john's grieving
on the air he's grieving the american
the american dream wow
just found out how close socialism is to
your back door it's expensive
wow problem is you run out of other
people's money
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today have you ever made a dumb
decision with zeros on the end because
you didn't do your research
yeah me too most people make choices
based on feelings or opinions especially
when they're buying a house but when it
comes to real estate market
feelings aren't your friends check your
facts find out
what you can actually afford research
what's trending in home prices talk to a
reputable real estate agent in your
area like one of our endorsed local
providers never buy a house without the
facts again if you will text the word
house to 33 789 you'll get an
agent to help you make smart decisions
text house two three three
seven eight nine alex was with us in
vancouver british columbia hi alex how
are you
hi i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay i'm calling for me because i have a
question about buying a car
i want to know if i'm in the right
position to buy a car and if so how much
i should spend
okay um so i'm a fourth year university
student i make
40k a year right now but i project that
to go to 60 or 70k
once i graduate this summer
i do have student loans i have about 31
000
in student loans but i actually have the
loan in full in an investment account
because here in canada we get a small
grant portion with the loan
so i just spend the grant portion and i
put the loan aside so i can pay it back
in full after
like this like this summer
when you graduate well um
once you graduate you have a six-month
grace period so i'll keep it in the
investment until
it's like i have to start repaying it
nah just pay it off yeah i would pay
that sucker off
yeah just be done with it side issues
okay so what's the question about the
car
so my parents are gifting me some money
they had a 175
000 settlement come to them and
i'm wanting to buy a vehicle i have two
vehicles right now
i have one vehicle that's worth about
three thousand and one that's worth
about seven thousand
and i'm hoping to put that money
together add a little bit from
um my parents investment on top of it
and buy a vehicle
my parents are going to give me 15 000
but they said if i buy a vehicle
they'll top it up to 20 000 to help me
out so it kind of gives me some
incentive
i guess my question is that the vehicle
that i'm driving right now
is very reliable and there's nothing
wrong with it but i just want a vehicle
that does all-wheel drive
but i want to make sure i'm doing it the
right way especially because i want to
be able to pay for my master's degree
in about a year from now and i have a
long-term goal of buying a house
so i just want to know how to go about
it the right way given i have all these
moving pieces
good good good very very well thought
out good for you
okay in general if you're a hundred
percent debt free and you pay
cash for the car uh no more than half
your annual income
and you're not going to be approaching
that and that half your annual income
this summer is going to be
70 000 so i'd be 35 000 and you're not
talking about spending that much on a
car i can tell
so you're talking about buying like a 15
000 car aren't you
that's what i was thinking i almost did
buy a 24 000
car but i had your voice in the back of
my head saying that that might not be
smart
yeah well the only thing i'm worried
about is i want you have enough cash
left over after this car purchase to
finish your masters because that's more
important than the car
yeah so what's it cost to do the masters
probably about 20 000 i think okay so
let me let me catch up then so you have
10 worth of vehicles your parents are
going
to give you 20. that's 30. if you spend
15 you're gonna have 15 left and you
need
20. yeah and where you gonna get the
other five to get your masters
well i'll be working and my expenses are
about two thousand a month
so i'll be able to save i think so
you're gonna pay cash for your masters
for whatever amount you don't have left
in savings
if you can pull that off and buy a
fifteen thousand dollar car i'm good
with it
and then whatever that okay you don't
buy a 20 000 car
yeah okay that's what i was thinking
because you're not gonna because that's
gonna leave you ten thousand on the hole
on your master
and that's gonna be tough to pull off
with work money
mm-hmm yeah
yeah well 15 15 000 is very reasonable
car you can get a great car for that
and your master's is like on a scale of
1 to 10 a 10 and a car
is a 2. yeah very important not
important
i would be tempted to keep my car and
get through my master's degree
yeah especially if you say you got a
reliable car it may not look pretty and
it's and all that but
mom and dad are gonna give her an extra
five she can make the 15 with that extra
five
and it's no net net loss so if they're
doing that to get the car
then yeah i would do it but again i'm
not going 16 i'm not going 17 i'm not
going 20.
i think 15 is your cap and that's
selling both the other cars you don't
get to keep any pets around
right they've all got to go so you put
five for mom and dad that's the extra
five they gave you
and the ten from your car cars into a
car
that's reasonable but here's the thing
don't if you go screwing around with it
more than that you're going to leave
yourself vulnerable
and you're going to have an excuse in
your mind to get a loan for that masters
and i'm not going to go with that
neither is john especially on a
depreciating asset like a vehicle
yeah it's the wrong direction wrong
stuff to put money into
logan is in chicago hi logan what's up
hi dave hi dr dee how are you guys doing
today great man what's up
so um long story short i graduated in
the class of 2020
i decided not to go to college due to
cove that i was going to go to music
school and
well live music isn't exactly around
right now um i got a job making about 70
80 000
a year i paid off all of my debt i've
got a lovely girlfriend i plan to marry
and i'm
really kind of struggling with where i
go financially from here
what did you stumble into an 80 000 job
i sell cars at a local dealership wow
well done man
good for you thank you okay
so you're 19 you make 80 grand you don't
have any debt
and your question is what to do now
basically where do i go from here i've
you know now i've got
very few responsibilities i still live
at home i pay rent to live at home
but that's a very small portion i've got
a decent amount of income coming in
am i saving that money for a house do i
start working towards like an engagement
ring this is these are the kind of
questions i'm asking
all of the above for goal one is build
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses if you weren't living at
home
okay if you had an apartment and you
needed three to six months of expenses
utilities
rent food all that kind of stuff you
need to talk about moving out
probably in the next six months or so
and get your own
place and then your emergency fund is
your first goal
probably the ring is your second goal
and then begin saving for whatever
buying a house or whatever beyond that
so with uh i guess in my situation it
would
it seems more fun to make more financial
sense that i have a good
situation here at home to bank the money
rather than go out and spend the
extra 600 plus a month it would be for
an apartment
well for a little while uh but there's a
point you become a man
and you move out of your mommy's
basement and so the sooner you do that
the more likely that's going to become
um and so uh if you were marrying my
daughter i would want you to have lived
on your own and paid your own freaking
bills for a little while
i don't want you moving from your
mommy's basement to be my daughter's
husband
i can totally understand that okay and
that's just that's a matter of
development i i i
100 agree with that and i i would
it's hard when you want to invest and
and get this roi all my money
that three to six months man is just to
protect you yeah and it's not there to
grow it's not there to be shiny it's
just there to be your own personal bank
for yourself
yeah the the money you're going to spend
living on your own
is an investment in your own growth
maturity
and growing up and figuring out who you
are and it's a good investment
and it's an investment in say preserving
your relationship it's not giving your
dad the middle finger i mean it's just
thank you for the
you know for the launch pad uh and thank
you for not allowing me to have failure
to launch and so
yeah you know you go do that and then
you have your emergency fund in place
before you do that and you you know so
i'm not saying you've got to move out
tomorrow i said six months
but in six months you ought to be making
80 grand you ought to pile up what ernie
a lot of money you gotta have some money
man i mean so
where you spend it on you know i mean a
ring and
an emergency fund and move out and there
you go
that's what i would do you do whatever
you want brother i appreciate you
listening
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
[Music]
damaris is with us damaris is in new
york city hi damaris how are you
hi i'm doing well thank you so much for
taking my call
my pleasure how can we help
my husband and i currently have about a
hundred and thirteen thousand dollars in
debt which just does not include our
home
we have um approximately 10 000 days and
savings for
emergencies in case anything happens
with the home
we have our son and we're about to start
foster caring
and we're just we've been living simple
we've paid off twenty seven thousand
dollars in credit cards so those are
gone
good and we're just yeah we're just
trying to decide
do we pay use the ten thousand dollars
to help pay towards the debt and bring
us down to the one thousand
emergency fund um being that you know we
have a home and we have
our our someone in us to enforce a child
we're not we're just not really sure
if we should save that money um uh
or you know use that towards so what is
the 113 thousand in debt
we have uh about nineteen thousand or so
in a car loan and then
ninety four thousand student loans
between my husband and i and what's your
household income
uh currently my husband makes 68. i am
making
unfortunately twelve thousand a year um
i used to make a lot more but
uh one coveted i lost my job and
um working two days a week i used to
make fifty two thousand
okay when do you think you'll be back
for a book um
well i'm a bookkeeper so i've been
looking for work on the bookkeeping job
but most jobs now want a degree and i
don't have
i didn't get to finish school i don't
have my degree yet
um in new york city a non-degree
bookkeeper can make 52
with experience yeah i'm actually in
doable
jersey yeah but i mean it's still it's
still that same market that's doable
um it's not it's not instantaneous but i
mean your life did not end because you
didn't have the only
job in new jersey that someone paid 52
000 for bookkeeping that's just
for a non-degree bookkeeper that's not
true they're they're there so
that's good the good news is you're
going to be back if you want to be are
you going to go back
oh i've been looking since october for
in conjunction with bishop i was working
actually three jobs at one time just
because i want to get a
you know take care of family but now i'm
making now those two others fell off
uh they ended the contract ended yeah um
and so i'm still looking um i even
started doing doordash just to get money
coming in
while i'm looking okay i'll tell you
what i want you to go to kencoleman.com
ken is one of our ramsey personalities
that does a show on sirius
and on 75 radio stations across america
he's not in your market
but he's one of our team members here
and he teaches people how to land jobs
and how how to focus on their career
there's tons of free resources there
on landing a job and doing a more
effective efficient
job search than the traditional job
search okay he's going to help you a
bunch with that i'm going to give you a
copy of his book
free it's called the proximity principle
but it's ken
coleman.com now when you land that job
it's going to lower your fear
substantially
you're kind of in a medium-sized storm
and i'm not sure you should be on the
baby steps right now you might should
push
pause and you guys just pile up as much
cash as you can pile up and then you
land that job
and then you clean out that account and
go down to a thousand dollars and start
baby step
one baby step two immediately tearing
into this debt
again okay
i'm sorry we were doing really well and
then this happened so you know
yeah and um that's how we picked up the
27k before so
you lost almost half your household
income yes
yeah is now a great time to be fostering
sounds like there's a lot of stress and
a lot of heat in that home
and man fostering it's such a
it's such an honorable thing to do and
it is hard
it is hard um you know we played about
it and uh we were
um uh put on hold because of covid and
then
uh just literally three or four weeks
ago they called us saying hey
are you so interested and in our hearts
we've always wanted to and we just felt
like if they're calling us
god's timing and we're really happy i
mean god knows we have foot on a plate
we're very blessed we're happy with what
we have
and we're just trying to you know be
thankful and
if we can help another child in this
situation that's just kind of where our
heart is at
yeah i get that in that i hear i hear
you yeah that was what yeah i wanna
always go back and this is a an
over an overdone um analogy but
you gotta put your oxygen mask on first
before you put your oxygen mask on your
kids
and you guys got to be healthy your
marriage has to be good you got to knock
this
debt out you've got to figure out what
you want to do with employment or stay
at home
it sounds like a lot of moving pieces
and to bring a kid into that
intentionally man it's so it's a it's a
it's a
wonderful thing to do but man it's gonna
just add another layer a big layer
of weight into that home yeah agreed
yeah okay so push pause and pile up cash
on the money piece
go to kingcoleman.com hold on kelly i'll
give you a copy of proximity principle i
want you to land that job super fast
and then i want you to push play which
means you are going down to a thousand
dollars
and you're going to put everything on
the debt and you're going to list your
debts smallest to largest and you're
going to pay off 113 000 in 36 months
and you're going to be 100 debt free
three years from today
but that's how your process is going to
go down but you don't want to half do it
and say i'm going to keep the 10 and
then i'm going to keep paying on the
debt
now let's either let's either say it's a
storm and we're on pause and we're
piling up cash
or we're down to a thousand dollars and
we're game on whichever it is
i think you're in the middle of a storm
and you hadn't really calculated that
because you lost half your annual income
that's what it sounds like emma's with
us in austin texas hey emma
welcome to the ramsay show hi guys how
are you
good what's up oh okay i
am in a major um i guess you could
i want to say uh like catastrophe or
just kind of some kind of
explosion right now and i really need
your help with making a decision
um for our family um we are
my husband took a job about five and a
half hours away
um i don't work but um
i'm just not sure we're really close
i've been putting everything towards
our um our debt and we're already paid
about why are you not moved with him
no he just took it just happened when
it's not
uh like two weeks ago okay so
you own a home we own two homes
are they up for sale no one has a renter
in it
and the other one i'm honestly in the
middle of doing foundation work
repair okay i literally have a leak
underneath my slab right now
so you're going to stay at home for a
little while until that's you're going
to stay away from him for a little while
until that gets fixed and then you're
going to get on the market
well i i don't know because i don't know
what's going on our marriage has been
shaken a little bit
and so i'm very nervous because it feels
like all
aspects of my life are not solid
does that make sense
yeah yeah i'm i'm really uh
not in a good mental place and so i need
clarity um
the the reason why our marriage is not
in a good place is because i found that
he was taking money
secretly out of our 401k or his 401k
and so i don't have 100 confidence
you know or when did you find this out
about two months ago what was he doing
with the money
um honestly it was between um
just things that he wanted and guns
because he wanted to be have a gun
collection
toys and i
thought how old is he the 40s
so is his job that he took five hours
away is that a
is that a move was that a power play
um it could be it definitely
and i've been asking you know like we've
been you know pension pennies for a
while now
and so this is more money um closer
to his family not necessarily my family
did y'all did y'all make this decision
together
uh i would say 80
him and 20 me i said i'm supporting you
i'm i support you
but i also still you don't need to do
anything until you guys get in the
marriage counselor's office
asap yeah yeah there's no no you don't
need to make any financial moves because
you got to decide
both of you have to decide what's going
to happen here going forward
and and so while you're fixing the
foundation on the house let's fix the
foundation on the marriage
it's way harder and way more important
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
our scripture of the day proverbs 18 15
the heart of the discerning
acquires knowledge for the ears of the
wise
seek it out
brian herbert said the capacity to learn
is a gift the ability to learn is a
skill the willingness to learn
is a choice that's a strong quote
i like that one maria is with us maria's
in california hi maria welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi dave thank you for taking my call my
honor what's up
hi so i am 20 years old i have about
30 000 in savings and i just wanted to
get your
opinion on what i should do with that
money whether that is putting
putting it in a roth ira or uh saving it
for a down payment in the future
um for a house okay what
are you working you in college what are
you doing yeah i'm in college i'm
in my third year um i
i'll be graduating next may good
um and i'm working part-time with a
degree in what
and earth science and hopefully i
um i'm able to change that to a degree
in geology
very cool okay so
um what are you going to do for a living
when you get your degree
um well i'm thinking about going into
hydrogeology
doing work in that which is why i want
to target the
geology degree right now i'm doing an
internship with
the water district here in orange county
um
so i'm getting the experience uh that
i'll need in the future
uh with this internship um so yeah
that's kind of
what my goal is right now okay so when
you finish all of this and you get the
dream job what does it pay
i don't know what a hydro geologist gets
paid you have to tell me
yeah they get paid um i think starting
it's about 80
uh 80k a year yeah and then it goes up
to 120.
and how long is it going to be before
you complete this field of study
um well if i if i go to earth science
um way i think i'm maxed out at like 90
which is why i want to do an extra year
so if i do that extra year and go into
geology i would
be graduating may of 2023 and then i can
um
i would have kind of a bigger pay range
in the future which would um
i think from what i've seen it's about
120 280
with the hydrogeology and that will take
you
i'll take you an extra year yes kind of
like doing grad work in a sense but it's
not really
okay no yeah okay so uh
the twenty thousand dollars the best
investment
that maria can make mathematically is in
this investment called maria
completing that field of study
completing that degree with what you
just told me you're going to make as a
result
is worth the investment of the dollars a
lot more
than a mutual fund or roth ira will ever
pay you
so i want every dollar you've got
committed to you graduating and you
graduating debt-free
as soon as possible and pursuing that
line of income that you're telling me
you can make
yes every dollar maria is the best
investment maria has possible because
you've chosen a field of study
that's not left-handed puppetry you
actually can do something with it and
you figured out what that is and you
know
you didn't hesitate when i asked you how
what the career field looked like and
how
what you would be paid you already know
this is not a pipe dream you've got this
studied you
you've thought this through you're
working in it right now you've planned
it you're working the intern you're
doing everything right kiddo
thank you yeah i also i forgot to
mention um
for my my expenses for school i get
financial aid so i basically
everything's covered which is why i
didn't know if i
don't care about money i don't care i
don't care if you've got a hundred if
you save up a hundred thousand dollars
and you don't even need it go ahead and
save it up
and make sure that you graduate the day
you graduate
you get this job we'll start investing
and you can use that hundred thousand
dollars to buy your first house
okay but right now right now
that money is laying there to make sure
maria graduates and maria graduates
debt free john's got a phd
in higher education maria so i mean you
don't see this
kind of thing very often no this is a
laser focus
but when dave says all your expenses are
taken care of
here's what that means like most college
students will say
um tuition room and board dave also
means your engine's gonna fall out of
your car
he means you're gonna someone's gonna
throw a rock through your back
windshield or you're gonna need some
more
cl whatever the thing is so get to the
finish line
owing nobody anything does that make
sense
okay yeah it does it does make sense
that's job one
job two is get to the finish line with
fifty thousand bucks in the bank
okay and some great connections and no
one
no investments made yet but you're 23
years old at that point making
six figures and you're going to be very
wealthy because you are a laser focused
chick i mean you're amazing
thank you so proud of you very well done
if we could train america to do that it
might be
i don't know man let's like think about
it bro
i mean the number of people getting a
degree in beer pong is scary
all right helen is with us in
fayetteville hey helen what's up
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
so my husband and i are on baby steps
four
five and six and
we would really like to get our house
paid off in the next
18 to 24 months
but i'm wondering does it make sense
for us to back off our
retirement investing a little bit
to free up some money to throw at the
mortgage
and just to give you a fuller picture
balance on your mortgage 250
000. so how much you're going to back
off and how quick what's it going to
change the numbers
well so uh we currently have about 425
000 in retirement
he is 50 i'm 49. i wouldn't want to ask
i ask how much you're going to back off
and how fast it's going to pay off the
mortgage because it's
probably not going to do what you think
it's going to do well
so we're currently only setting aside
about 10 percent
uh we're maxing out the roth 401k and
ross i'm self-employed roth ira
and then we've got some cash set aside
beyond
our um six-month emergency fund
and we're kind of we're in that position
of right can we start
throwing this at the mortgage or do we
need to do outside
investment outside i'm sorry one more
time what'd you tell me your household
income is
about 400 000. oh you didn't tell me
okay
all right so if you make 400 000 and you
don't want to put in 15
you only want to put in 10 how much cash
have you got set aside
um let's see above our six months um
about fifty thousand dollars
okay so see five percent eighty thousand
yeah yeah so if you do that that's gonna
pay uh it's eighty thousand dollars a
year
um did i do that right i did do that
right yeah that's eighty thousand
dollars a year
it's five percent um
so you're if you do that if you keep
putting only putting 10 in and you take
that 50 000 and throw it at the 200
mortgage
you should be debt-free in 18 months
like you said right
right and then the rest of your life the
rest of your life you just invest like
crazy people
okay okay yeah i'm in for that
okay all right well i just i know that
percent is
um really where where you like well it's
a lock but
you understand you're in the top one
half of one percent of income earners
so that you know you also don't need to
spend ten percent of your budget on food
because you get really large
because you know things kind of start to
change with this kind of scale
so right you know you know the good news
the great news about this is you guys
are actually thinking about it
you're questioning whether you should
break a rule in the system
the dave system you know all that and so
you're really
you know and obviously you're not dumb
dumb people don't make 400 grand
so nothing i know of um
well maybe one example but
i just went there in my head but anyway
the uh i'm just not gonna say it so
no you're fine you're fine you're you're
gonna do great you're being intentional
you're being thoughtful you're being
wise
you're gonna pay off your house in 18
months and you're not gonna skip a beat
you're gonna have millions of dollars
in your accounts and you're going to be
great so proud of you very well done
very well done john good show thanks man
good job james and
kelly in the booth i'm dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you